Speaker 1: I want to talk about, in all seriousness,
this is sort of one of the better interviews
I've seen with Donald Trump, thanks to the
interviewer Adam Shapiro from Yahoo Finance.
Not a guy.
I was familiar with that.
At least I remember.
Ahead of this interview, Adam Shapiro did
a 22 minute long interview with Donald Trump.
It's absolutely horrifying for Donald Trump.
But Adam Shapiro actually makes a real attempt
to get Trump to answer the questions that
he's asking and to insist by asking again
when Trump goes elsewhere, it's still unhinged
Trump.
But Adam Shapiro was actually able to sort
of get Trump to weigh in on certain things.
Let's start with a clip.
The topic is 2024.
How and well, how and when would Trump decide?
What does he think about the possible challenge
faced that he faces from Ron DeSantis, the
sort of Trumpian to the extreme governor of
Florida?
A lot of different questions here.
Let's just jump right into it.
Speaker 3: Mr. Trump, when you consider what
it's going to take for you to decide if you're
going to run for president, this would be
one of the issues.
Curious, though, would be
Speaker 5: one who would just agree to just
dropping into one of
Speaker 3: many issues, I would imagine.
But but you'd have to win the nomination.
By the way,
Speaker 1: Trump, Trump already just talking
over Adam Shapiro, not even letting him get
to the.
It is.
It's typical Trump.
But Adam Shapiro really does a pretty good
job here.
Speaker 5: Not me.
I'm curious, how would you?
I'll give you a couple of others.
Well, how would you how would you say,
Speaker 3: do you think a Republican like
Ron DeSantis in the primaries?
How what would it take for you to beat him?
Yeah.
Speaker 5: Well, number one, I don't think
I will say is because I don't see that if
I if I did it.
I don't say that.
I think most people would drop out.
I think he would drop that.
And if I faced him, I beat him like I would
beat everyone else.
Speaker 1: So this is interesting because
Trump is saying he believes if he ran, a lot
of people would drop out either out of respect
to Trump or for whatever.
That's interesting to hear.
Speaker 5: And you take a look at what's going
on in the polls, where I have way over 90
percent and in some cases, 98 percent approval
rating and the Republican Party, because I
did a I did a great job as president, despite
all of the hoaxes, despite the Russia, Russia,
Russia.
Speaker 1: Now it's not completely true.
What Trump is saying Trump is dominating the
primary field for 2024.
But his approval is less relevant than the
number who say they would vote for him to
be the nominee, and that's about 58 percent.
It's a high number.
It's still the highest number anybody else
has.
But it is not, you know, Trump by saying 90
percent or whatever is acting like he would
get 90 percent of the primary vote here.
He may well have 80 or 90 percent approval,
though he never really cites sources.
He's polling in between 50 and 60 in terms
of the actual primary
Speaker 5: that now has been exposed as a
total fraud.
Despite everything, we did a great job.
Largest tax cuts in history rebuilt the military.
Space Force took care of our vets 92 percent
approval rating in the VA for the first time
ever, way higher than ever before.
You know, we did a job that nobody's done
and had COVID not come and interrupted.
We had the greatest economy again.
Say what you want.
We had a hundred and sixty million jobs.
Our country was never close to that.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, we've talked before
about the labor participation rate sort of
hoaxes the population of the U.S. grows.
And so most of the time, we have more people
working than ever before or close to it and
more people not working than ever before or
close to it.
That's just a political game that they play.
Speaker 3: It's inevitable that Mr. Trump,
it's not.
What I want, it's just the jobs created during
your administration, I think that it's the
Bureau of Labor Statistics points out it was
something like six point four million jobs,
and during the Obama administration, it was
seven million jobs.
But when I hear what you're saying about the
need for perhaps you to run in 2020, for what
I'm hearing you say is you are going to run,
are you?
Speaker 5: No, I haven't.
I haven't said that.
I said that if I do run, I think that I'll
do extremely well.
And I'm looking not only at polls, I'm looking
at the enthusiasm, what we did a great job.
Now when you say what you had just said, the
economy, as you know, was very bad when he
took over.
So the economy wasn't terrible when I took
over, but it wasn't great.
It was stagnant.
It's slow.
I guess it was the I guess it was the worst
recovery since the depression of 1930.
Speaker 1: OK, so Trump getting into his very
strange and random kind of historical claims.
But the truth is the economy was generally
good under Trump until COVID hit.
There was job creation under Trump, but the
the rate of job creation diminished compared
to under Obama and Trump got lower job creation
with a significantly higher deficit.
So we can analyze that for what it is.
But let's make sure we're actually analyzing
the real data.
Next, Trump goes on to I'm sorry, Adam Shapiro
moves on to Steve Bannon, where there seems
to be a disagreement.
Bannon says he talks to Trump regularly.
Trump's like, No, I don't talk to the guy.
I haven't talked to him for a long time.
Speaker 3: Mr. Trump, there's one last question
I want to ask you as we wrap, and it's because
I covered your administration for the first
year and a half.
I was in Washington, and I remember that Steve
Bannon lost your trust when he spoke to Michael
Wolff for that right.
And he left the administration.
But he's returned your trust, and I'm curious
what he did to get back into your good graces
and to get your trust.
Yes.
Speaker 5: Well, she didn't get along with
certain people in the administration, so I
understand that that happens and it happens
with all administrations, frankly, and for
a period of time.
He didn't, just didn't do it, and I understand
that.
But if you look at Steve over the last three
years, he sees what a great job we've done
as an administration.
When you look at all of the things that I've
enumerated, plus many others, I mean, think
Speaker 1: like, no, this is not an answer
to the question notice, but but eventually
Adam Shapiro jumps in with what is the real
question, right?
Speaker 5: Where you can get medical treatment
of something experimental if you're in a bad
shape, if
Speaker 3: he was advising you towards the
end of your administration.
Excuse me, Mr. Bannon was advising you towards
the end of the administration.
Speaker 5: No, not at all.
No, I haven't spoken to Steve almost at all.
No, he wasn't.
But I know that he's got a show that's very
successful.
He says he
Speaker 3: does.
So is he lying when he says he was talking
to you in the last months of your administration?
Speaker 5: Very little which people are a
little nervous, even I smoke very little,
but I will tell you he was very supportive.
Speaker 1: So someone is lying has certainly.
But now Trump backing off by saying we spoke
very little, which makes it, you know, maybe
mildly plausible.
One last clip here is Donald Trump asked about
cryptocurrency is just kind of interesting
Speaker 3: that a great many of our viewers
here on the Yahoo Finance platform are into
cryptocurrencies, and the well-known bitcoin
investor Anthony Pompliano was just on my
program talking about China's crackdown on
crypto.
He says that's a big gain for the United States.
You have a relationship with the Chinese President
Xi Jinping.
What do you think Xi Jinping is up to?
And is this crackdown on crypto good for the
US?
Speaker 5: Well, I think he wants to do his
own currency, whether it's crypto or otherwise,
and one of the reasons that we have to be
very careful is we have a currency right now,
the dollar and I'm a big fan of the dollar.
I'm a big fan of our currency and I don't
want to have other currencies coming out and
hurting or demeaning the dollar in any way
and China is looking to do.
China is certainly not looking to back the
dollar, but right now they're based on the
dollar, and they would probably have to stay
that way unless we do something very foolish
in our country.
Speaker 1: So the takeaway here is Trump really
doesn't know what he's talking about, but
I liked the interview and that the interviewer
prevented Trump from going totally off the
rails.
He kept Trump focused enough where you could
tell Trump doesn't really understand these
issues in any kind of serious way.
Very overall.
Very nice job there.
By Adam Shapiro on Yahoo Finance.
That interview not getting a lot of views
at all.
Some of those clips only have five thousand
views on the